Hi, this is a presentation on
‘Is it okay to pursue functional programming on the front end?’
Let us begin the presentation
Hi, I’m working at Devsisters
As a web front end developer, I am Kim Minsu
I am interested in all technologies used at web front end
Lately I’ve been interested in functional programming
Hi, I am Lee Chang-Hee
I did front and back-end developing at Devsisters
Usually I contribute to JavaScript and Go
Functional programming,
As the photo shows, I’m sure you think about things like
Monad, category theory, and those complex things
But in this presentation, I will refrain from going too deep into the theory
I will instead explain more on how it can be applied in reality
Functional programming processes data as a pure function
And it moves away from side effects as the programming paradigm
I’m sure you know that much
But you may be wondering that something at the front-end,
DOM work, async data patching
These actions may incur side effects,
I’m sure you think that
And it’s all very correct
But functional programming,
It is not that it uses no side effect at all
It uses side effect and pure function at the same time
And maintains them together
And this program paradigm combines the functions generated here
So how did we implement the functional programming to the team?
Let me explain that now
First, doing separate studies myself,
I learned about the related theories with my personal studies
And then in my actual project
I applied some simple functional methods
To write the code
And the teammates who were with me on the project saw that code
And began studying with me
So we started the functional programming inside the team
And while we were studying within the team
We had a case where we had to maintain
Something complex as you see
Four inputs for one form,
And each form has separate verification logic
And in each different form
We had some in-common verification processes as well
Change-Hee will cover that more at the back in more depth
Of many functional programming libraries
We chose fp-ts in our development
So why did we choose fp-ts?
fp-ts supports something many functional programming languages support,
Which is the type abstraction
And these abstractions
Follow the theories based on functional programming very well
And there is a variety of library ecosystem that can be used together
So before we go into actual cases
Let me show you some needed type abstraction
And utility functions
Option type abstraction consists of
None and Some type
The code looks broken here, I don’t know why
Option type is each container with the selective A type
With the A type value, Option type is Some instance
If there is no value, Option type is None instance
Option type is the effect of calculation that can fail in general
Now here are some examples of uses of Option type
Option type can be brought in with the first line
Using the Some type and None, we can create each type of instances
Finding an index with a specific value in an array
If there is no value for findindex function
-1 is returned
If the value-finding is successful
The Some instance with the index value is returned
If the value is not found, None instance is returned
This is the actual use
There is value 1 within the array
Some tag
And the object that has the 0 value for the array index
Is returned as you see here
There is no value 4 within the array
Second, we can see that the None instance with the None tag is returned
Also, with the fromNullable function
We can create the Option type again
fromNullable function
When nullable value is sent to the argument, None instance is returned
Conversely, the non-nullable value
If the not-nullable value is sent to the argument
The Some instance with that value is returned
And using the fromPredicate function, we can create the Option instance as well
fromPredicacte has the function that returns Boolean as the argument
IsNumber function is delivered to fromPredicate function
To generate getOptionNumber function
In the case of isNumber function returning true
Some instance is returned
If isNumber function returns false, None instance is returned
Next, Either type
Either type is similar to Option type
The two types express one value
Either instance is Left and Right instance
Either type, to process missing value
It can be used in place of Option
Option’s None instance
Is replaced with Left instance that can include in the value
In general, Left expresses failure
And Right, success
Let’s look at some examples of uses of Either type
Either is often used in generating exceptions
In this example
I will use tryCatch function as well
It has something that turns text into JavaScript object
The parse function converted to Either
Using tryCatch, if the original parse function generates exception,
It returns Left that contains error
If parse function is realized well
It returns Right that contains JavaScript object
Like the example, in the case of a successfully returned object,
the object with the Right tag value
And Right property is returned
For the exception
The one with Left tag and value is returned
For Either type, same as Option,
fromNullable and fromPredicate can be used
Some difference, for Either type, when Left is returned it gets
The basic value for use as argument
If nullable value is given
The Left instance with the value from the above function is returned
For the opposite case,
Right instance with the value is returned well
fromPredicate function is the same as fromNullable function
When Left instance is returned, the value to be used
is returned in the second argument additionally with the returning function
When Left instance is returned
The function sent as the second argument to fromPredicate function is run
The value is contained
And the Left instance is returned
If the function given to the first argument returns true
The instance with the value is returned
Next is the Task instance and Task type
Task type expresses the fail-proof async calculation
The async calculation that can fail
Can use TaskEither that uses Either as well
That I mentioned earlier
Here is a written lead function that runs
Async action with the user’s input
Lead function, if the program is functioning
It will keep on waiting for the user input and it won’t fail
As the photo shows, we see how the lead function is working well
TaskEither type, same as Either type
Can use the tryCatch function
If the Promise is resolved
The Right instance with the resolved value is returned
Conversely for the reject, the function delivered to the second argument is run
The return value of the second argument function
which is the return value is returned in the Left instance
It’s async function
Using the async keyword it runs the function
As I explained before
We can see the returned instances for the right cases
Next is fp-ts utility function called pipe
As the example shows, there’s a currying function
That adds the two numbers
Using this add function
I made the function that adds 1, 2, 3
As the diagram shows
If each function is run in a sequence
How can we call in the function?
In general, from within the function call
We can fuse in the function as we call it in
However, what happens if there are more and more functions to fuse?
We can see how the code is getting really complicated
To make the visuals more convenient
What if it gains every time a function is called?
I’m sure the same Callback Hell situation will occurs
With the pipe function, the function can be fused simply like this
It is much easier to follow how the function is fused
We just need to read the value and function delivered as argument to pipe function
From Left to right
The utility function pipe
Is suggested as JavaScript operator now
How can we use the type abstractions we talked about before?
To use type abstractions
We need to know about a few functions that can be used together
First is the map function
It does the same thing as the map function at the JavaScript array
And, map function is also called a mapping function
The map functions of type abstractions
All receive the A type value
And return B type value in the function it gets
As the code states, for Some type
The function delivered to Map function is run
Following along the pipe
String type, meeting with fromNullable function, became Option
And following the signature of the function delivered to map function
We see how the type changes
Conversely, with the None instance delivered
The function delivered to the map function does not run
Because the function delivered to fromPredicate returns false
None instance is delivered
Meaning the result of the code is None
Next is chain function
Chain function is used to see whether to continue the calculation or not
Using the result of the calculation before the operation
The later calculation is done in sequence
Let me talk about the Either type chain as the example
Multipleby10 function
Multiplies by 10 and returns instance if the input is a number
If the input is not a number
It returns the Left instance with the text
Increment gets number and returns the Right instance that
Contains the value that adds one
With fusing this function you can make a new function
The delivered value when this function was called is text
So this multipleby10 function returns Left instance
So, the increment function delivered to chain does not run
Left instance is returns in sum
Conversely, if the delivered value is number 10
Multipleby10 function returns the Right instance with the number 10
Right instance is delivered to chain function
So the increment function delivered to chain is called and we see
That the Right instance with one added is returned
Finally let me talk about the match and fold function
Match and fold serve the same function
For Option type, Some and None
Either type, Left and Right
For each case, the function to run is delivered to run
If the delivered value to pipe is not 0
fromPredicate function returns Some instance
If Some instance is delivered to match function
The function delivered to the second argument is run
If the first delivered value to pipe is 0
FromPredicate function returns None instance
If None instance is delivered to match function
The function delivered to the first argument is run
So that was it on some type abstractions, pipe function, and how to use
The type abstraction
So let’s now talk about real life examples that were resolved with this
So something we talked about before,
Using the abstraction data type, let’s see how we solved the actual problems
As said, we were building a job recruiting website
And the form for application ended 8 input maintenance
We first got the input from the user in the form
And validate to see if the entered value is correct
if it’s not validated, error message should be there
That was the common problem for all
If there’s too many fields the code looks ugly
So let’s just consider one aspect, the phone number field
If we’re to make this application form
The state managing phone number value
And the state with the error message with the issue with the phone number value
These are the two states
And there will be a logic that validates whether the phone number is correct
And whenever the user changes the input, with onChange event
It’ll keep the state value managed
In form event toad let’s like form onSubmit
Before the form submission it reviews the whole thing again
The component data to show to the user
Input from the user and the span with error messages
It’s wrapped simply with span here
Those dome objects will exist
So let’s sum up what I said before
To realized a field that can be validated
Two states, one field validating function
And the event handler function detecting field’s input value, we need these four
But in fact, maintaining the eight inputs
16 states should be maintained within the component
Event handler and validating logic should be written separately
Here I only tried three
If it is realized with the say we mentioned
This is how The component code looks like
But we wanted to minimize the number of codes within the component
So we thought on how to solve this issue
I’m sure you’re thinking of the how yourself as you’re listening
In fact, the library to resolve this issue
Is already well made, like React-Hook-Form or Formik
So most cases we use that
But for us, there was a consensus within our team to try and apply
The functional programming
So the fp-ts library that we tried in other projects,
We wanted to apply it here as well
before solving the issue, using this fp-ts which should be rewritten?
We analyzed the issue again
First, we need two states for maintaining input value and error message
And refresh the states if the input is in
Validate to see if the value is correct, if not, send error message
But here, the object or realization for each field differs
Only with the three: input value, error message and validating function
Here, all other parts are something worked commonly on all fields
So the input value, error message, validating function
These three values, abstracting the code into the form of something exerted from outside
We thought writing the code will be much easier
So to solve that issue, we took four steps
Here I will show you the codes we actually applied for production
To show you how it works and how it’s used in this use case
First, we made the common validation function
Validation function parameter has validator here
The functions to validate each field
And the error message for user when the validation fails
And the return value of the function is the query function for the validated value
Those are the components
Function signature is this currying function
This function receives user input value
And it’s delivered to the function fromPredicate at Either
This fromPredicate gets two functions as the first argument
The first argument,
It’s a logic that checks for some value that’s being delivered here
So see, they get the value with the argument val
This value is moved to validator
So all inputs in validator through map function is moved to the function
To see if this value is correct according to the rules
So
If this value is correct, this fromPredicate
Returns the value the user input in Right type
If not, it gets the result value of the function over to the second argument
Here we will take the function’s result value, the value for the Left type as the error message
So here the simple error message is returned in this written function
Let’s see how it actually works
Here, when the user input is correct phone number
And a flawed phone number, each for Right and Left type
The input and error message are shown
And the validators that I talked about, are defined here
It’s something I showed you at the simple example component
In the validating function, if statement, validators, they are atomically divided
For validation, there are rules used in one field
But most cases it’s about the maximum or minimum length
Or the limit to characters
Those are the commonly used rules
So I wanted to make it reusable
And let’s see how we use the rules above
From the first to third, it’s numbers, starting with 01
And it doesn’t go over 11 characters, all three are true
But the last ‘minimum length 10’ rule
It’s not met, so false is returned
And then with the pre-made rules the validator for each field is made
This validating function, overall, pipe
Using the function pipe that I mentioned before
Here, the phoneNumber number input field that the user fills in
The user’s phone number is here first
And towards validate function, the first-made
Validation rules and error messages are moved over
So this initial value is required in this form
So is it over one character, meaning is there any input from the user?
So if there is no input from the user
‘It is required’ error message will be returned from Left type
If something is returned, right type will be returned
So the returned Either, Left or Right type
It moves to the Either chain function argument right after
Here, chain function gets Either type as the argument
If the received value is Left
Then it doesn’t work, it returns the input Left type as it is
If it’s Right type, then the validate function sent to chain as argument
To that function, Right type value is moved over as argument again
Here’s a simple example for you
No value is added, Left type’s ‘it is required’ error message
The wrong value for the second validate
Will now say ‘wrong format of numbers’
In the left type for the error message
If it’s all passed
The first phone number input from the user will be returned with the Right type
Yes, and everything until now
As a developer, to use it more conveniently, I made some custom hook
The custom hook we made has the name useStateWithValidator
As the name states, overall the interface is very similar to that of userState
This hook has two internal state, which are
As at the naive component in the beginning did,
The value maintaining state and error message maintaining state, the two are there
And here changeError, setting the error message
A function similar to setState is wrapped here
The return part for the error message as input
I’ll explain when I talk about StateValidator object below
Yes, and changeValue is a function similar to setState sending from inside to outside
Delivering new value to the validator to see if it’s the right value
So it’ll check whether left or right type is returned
And using Either’s match function
It will work differently for Left and Right type
Either match function has two functions as arguments
First, if the either as argument is left, the function to run
First, if the either as argument is right, the function to run
For left, function provided by  identity fp-ts is used
For identity, it literally returns the value moved over as the function’s argument
Right back, it’s a very simple function
Here the Left is always the error message
So here, it'd be good to understand that
the input error message that's been received is being returned right away
And for the Right type
It gets the input and does setState and returns the empty text
If there is an error message the string for the error message will arrive
If there is no issue, then the empty text I talked about
For the right type, the empty text will be returned
So it will move over
So finally with the moved over text
The error is set up
And we made an object called StateValidation separately
This isn’t something that changes the state every time the value changes
Like submitting a format, manually at a desired timing
Form validation should be done in some cases
And the validation function that can be used as a manual
And the value that can allow the user to see for the errors on field
It has the getter that can bring all that easily
I am running out of time, so I will move a little quickly
So with all four validating rules  we made
Let’s see how we improved the existing code; the highlighted parts
Here, using the field validating rules and custom hook
It can be a one line code
And change the value, validate at onChange event handle
Validate, set the error message, those things
It’s all internally processed in our custom hook
So it’s very simple unless we need some other special work
And for onSubmit, for that validation step
We used to add the value of each field to the field’s validator
To manually call them in
Here, the interface is all the same with the validation function at StateValidator
So only with the array of StateValidator it’s
Easier to manually validate all these fields
And for the error message the cited error state before
Here, using error getter at StateValidator
It’s not inside the component
But the user can just get the value and use it, that’s the change
So let’s sum up today’s presentation
What is functional programming?
What library fp-ts has that we used?
And how do we abstract the existing logic using that
And realize it?
So here is the upside and downside of this when we used it
First, type can safely define our problem better
And it resolves the problem too
And writing the code, ‘should this be covered by function or’
‘How should this side effect be processed?’
We could have all that functional programming thoughts for front end developments
And when the team applies new technology and concept
How does it get smoothly into the team?
We realized thinking about those
It connects to the downsides we felt
First, since it was the first time applying the functional program
So those who aren’t experienced or interested
They had a hard time writing and reading the code in the beginning
So we thought we need much more time for this to
Onboard on the project when we are using it
And we approached it with the mindset that
If possible, let’s write all codes functionally
But in fact, plain JavaScript
Can be cleaner and readable for some cases
So it’s not for all places, it should be selectively applied to where the project would look
Cleaner and more convenient with this
And there’s not much latest document and the official document isn’t too nice
So it was hard looking for the information to apply to the team first
The developer of fp-ts used to write something in series
But most of that is now deprecated
So we just use the unfriendly official document
To learn, that was the difficulty we went through
We’re over the time
That’s it for our presentation today, thank you